The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said the most beloved salat to Allah
meaning of the week
is salatul Fajr
on the day of Jumu' in Jama'.
So, you want to start a habit of coming
to the masjid, you want to especially
come to masjid at Fajr.
Jumu' is a good day to start that
habit. Especially young men, our young
men, we need them to fill the masjid at
all times.
[Silence]
Continuing in Riyadh as-Salihin in the
chapters
in the book of al-Manthurat wal-Mulah
the book of miscellaneous and
interesting and beautiful stories. He
begins this book of Riyadh as-Salihin
with the chapters
regarding ad-Dajjal and Ashrat
as-Sa', the signs of the Day of
Judgment
which we have been reading through.
The next narration that
we mentions the narration of last night
was regarding what?
Last night.
What did we talk about last night?
Sometimes I feel
I'm
So, yesterday we spoke about
Yathu aw Yahasiru al-Furatu an jabalin
min thahab.
No, that doesn't count. Yeah, you don't
get to just
finish my sentence for me and act like
you Oh, I knew that all along. No, okay.
So, that's what we mentioned yesterday.
Today, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam mentions to us a narration that
is far after that incident.
So, last night's narration and noble we
tells us
the narration
in which the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam
prophesied that at the at the you
know, near the day of judgement, near
the day of
Yawm al-Qiyamah, before ad-Dajjal
emerges
that the Euphrates River will uncover a
mountain of gold.
In another wording, a mountain of golden
treasure.
And the people will then start to fight
over it.
Out of every 100
how many will die in its cause? 99.
What is driving them to fight over this
mountain of gold and accept these very
dismal odds, 99 to 1, what call what
drives them
to or what conviction drives them to
participate in such a
in such an unwinnable I mean, 99 to
1, that's basically 100%. So, what
drives people at that time in that area
to fight that?
Ignorance, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam, well, that's implied,
disintegration of values, dignity,
right?
That's implied because only such an
environment would facilitate such
behavior, but he tells us
Yabunnu
Annahu Najih. Each one of them, if you
were to ask them, they are convinced
that they are the ones who are going to
be that one
out of 99. Each of them is convinced
that in spite of those dismal odds, 99
to 1, each of them is convinced that
they are that one,
right?
They're special.
They're very special. And this all leads
back into the generalized
attitude and behavior of people at
the end of time just before the Dajjal
emerges. So, for instance,
our Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam
tells us
Idha ra'ayta al-nas
[Arabic recitation]
bayna asabi'ihi
yaqulu
[Arabic recitation]
ra'yin bi ra'yihi
He says
that near the end of time when society
starts to kind of fall apart and these
giant mega huge international
governments start to govern and people
are viewed as numbers, this is all part
of the prophecies that our prophet tells
us will come to pass. He says, you will
see in that environment that people
there
meaning
that
people will not be separated by values
anymore.
Everybody will all be one community.
There's no good guys and bad guys.
Everyone is good and everyone is bad
simultaneously.
It's all a mess, a tangled mess, right?
he tells us that people's
trust
for each other and people's
and people's trustworthiness
will be almost all but absent, all but
gone. That value of
loyalty or that value of
trustworthiness
which will be incredibly rare.
He says and people will be as such and
he interlocked his fingers this.
Meaning that
the good and the bad, they're all
twisted together, right?
And one of the things that he tells us
that every person will have an opinion
and every person will be infatuated and
set
and enthralled by his or her own
opinion.
Where do opinions come from?
Well, not really. When a person
produces an opinion,
let's say a person says, "This is
wrong."
or this is right
or this is correct or this is incorrect.
What is
that?
Where does it come from?
It comes from what? From knowledge and
conviction, correct?
A person has experience, they have a
history, and they also have certain
knowledge. These things come together
and they produce what we see as what? As
an opinion.
And so, opinions are only as relevant as
the knowledge that they're based on, the
knowledge that they draw from.
And when opinions start to become
"My opinion is this, my opinion is
that." not based on knowledge and more
specifically not based on the Quran and
Sunnah, this is an incredibly dangerous
phenomenon.
And so, he tells us that everyone who
has an opinion will be
captivated, enthralled, convict
convinced, and dead set on his or her
own opinion.
for instance, let's say I come to
a person, let's say I come to Osama
here, and I want to tell him something.
I want to tell him this is right or this
is wrong.
Something he said, something he did,
something he he values. I say, "This is
right or this is wrong.
Is it possible
that I'm
correct and he is incorrect? I'm the
advisor, he is the advised. Is it
possible that I am correct as the
advisor and he is incorrect as the one
being advised?
Yes.
But here's another question.
Is it possible that even though I am
going out of my way
to moralize and advise, is it possible
that I am mistaken and he is actually
correct?
Yes.
But how many people when they seek out
to state their opinion will be convinced
or even even entertain the possibility
that they could be incorrect?
Very few.
Very few people.
And so
opinions
are only the
the result of a person's knowledge, a
person's experience, and a person's
values.
And for this reason the prophet
alayhi wasallam
he used to make dua
that he would seek refuge in Allah.
[Arabic recitation]
He would seek refuge in Allah from
knowledge that is unbeneficial, that is
inconsequential.
Why? Because it may seem neutral.
However, it all plays into what comes
out of a human being as far as actions
or statements or opinions.
So, this is a snapshot of things before
the emergence of a Dajjal. Here we have
a narration after a Dajjal when
Allah commands that the actual horn be
blown by
by which angel?
Israfael alayhis salaam.
So, listen to this narration.
He says
[Silence]
This is a truly haunting narration.
He tells us that at the end of time
Medina will be uninhibited
by human beings.
Because after the jail and after the
jail is slain and after Yajooj and
Majooj and after Isa alayhis salaam
passes away
in Sahih Muslim, the prophet tells us
that Allah will send a kind of breeze
that will
go under or as it comes in it will
affect
everyone who has in his heart even a
grain weight of belief and it will claim
their life.
Every single person.
Even in one narration, the prophet tells
us even if that person were in the belly
of a mountain, that breeze will
come to collect him. And so, everyone
with any belief in their heart will be
taken by that light breeze.
After that, there will only be the worst
of humanity on the earth.
Medina
Medina, why do people live there? What's
the only incentive to live in Medina?
Huh?
Islam, right? Belief. That's the only
driving force to live in Medina.
And so,
Medina will be completely uninhabited
near the end of time.
He tells us, and he paints for us a
picture that the only thing that will be
running in Medina will be wild animals.
Foxes and And he tells us in Muwatta
Malik, another wording of this
narration, that hatta yabulu yabulu al
tha'labu ala al minbar.
To the point that
even a fox will be in the masjid, wild
animals running around, and a wild fox
or animals will even urinate in the
place where the minbar is, where the
prophet's minbar once sat. Sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam. During this time,
the Kaaba will be dismantled. It'll be
taken apart brick by brick.
Right? Who will
destroy the Kaaba?
Does anyone know?
-huh. What's he What What is he
called?
Do you remember? Dhu way
right?
He will destroy the Kaaba trying to
extract the treasure that is buried
underneath the Kaaba.
And so
this place will be completely desolate.
He tells us
of
two
He tells us of two shepherds
that are from the area of Muzaynah.
Muzaynah is an area on the outskirts of
Medina.
They
will be headed with their flocks to
Medina for whatever reason. They're
going to Medina. They have their flocks
of livestock and they are on their way
to Medina.
They will be
yelling at their sheep
to try to control their sheep. A
shepherd, you know, when sheep stray a
little bit, you they learn commands to
try to keep the shepherd to try to keep
the flock together and headed in in a
coherent direction. And so as the sheep
start getting closer and closer to
Medina, the sheep will start to be
misbehaving
and they will start yelling at their
sheep.
So terrifying.
And what a what an eloquent description.
He says they'll be yelling at their
sheep to try to control them
as they head into Medina, but suddenly
they will find that their sheep are
acting skittish and wild.
The sheep
sheep are tame and controllable.
But they will suddenly start to see that
the sheep are acting
wild and uncontrollable.
Why is that?
Huh?
No, not because of wild animals. The
sheep will start acting wild
animals. They won't be able to control
these sheep.
Why? What would cause an animal to
behave this?
Huh?
Well, you know that you ever see animals
before an earthquake, for instance?
Or before a tornado?
They they sense something is off.
If a predator comes into a particular
area of the forest, what happens?
You stop hearing anything. It's dead
quiet in the forest.
Right? Because there's a predator
around. Animals sense things that we
don't sense.
As a matter of fact, animals can hear
the
the torment of people in their graves.
Is that not correct? They can hear the
torment of people in their graves.
And so,
the animals will sense that something is
wrong.
Something is wrong and and crazy
something is off balance.
There's something off kilter.
And so, these shepherds, they don't
sense what the animals sense. So,
they're yelling at their sheep. They're
We're speaking about moments before the
the blow into the horn. We're speaking
about minutes
before the blow into the horn.
As they get close to Medina, suddenly
their sheep will start acting wild, and
they will be yelling at their sheep, and
their sheep will be acting crazed and
wild. He says,
He says,
He says, "And they will make their way
through Thaniyyatul Wadaa'."
Do we know what Thaniyyatul Wadaa' is?
Thaniyyah, this is a a path on the
outskirts of Medina
that is referred to as the
area of
of departure.
You know, in airports where we have
kiss and goodbye
areas. Do you guys ever see that?
Those are in smaller airports
small towns, but it's where it's
referred to as Thaniyyatul Wadaa', the
the place of farewell, it's because
usually people when they would leave
Medina,
they would be accompanied by their
family members or friends or whatever
until they reach that area of
Thaniyyatul Wadaa', and they would hug
each other goodbye, and they would bid
one another farewell, and that is where
the traveler
departs Medina officially. It's
referred to as Thaniyyatul Wadaa', and
that's the place where the Prophet
Sallallahu Alayhi Wasallam what?
arrived through when he made Hijrah,
right?
Min Thaniyyatul Wadaa'.
All right?
and so, when they reach Thaniyyatul
Wadaa', meaning they're just about to
enter Medina,
they will fall flat their faces, meaning
the horn will be blown.
They will be frozen in place,
and then their souls will be collected,
leaving their bodies as empty husks.
They're just about to enter Medina at
Thaniyyat al-Wada.
So, this is a kind of image of
you know, what will happen when the horn
is actually blown.
[Silence]
question